[Music]
schools will be open and students will
be physically back in the classrooms on
monday but they're going to have to wear
a mask thank you for joining us i'm
christian casadas and i'm denise valdez
so over the next half hour we're going
to be giving you all the information you
need for back to school top to bottom so
let's start first with masks all
students and staff will be required to
wear them now there are 310 000 students
enrolled so far this year and 95 percent
of them have opted for in-class learning
there are a dozen schools offering
distance learning for people who are
taking that option and for those in
class mass and social distancing will be
back
it applies to all students as stated in
the memo
as far as with the students with special
needs i know that there are going to be
some exemptions made
the american academy of pediatrics has
said research consistently shows opening
schools in person doesn't necessarily
increase covet transmission when mask
and other protocols are followed the
school district says if a student does
have to stay home they'll make sure they
can still do classes from there
well denise the number of students who
need free or reduced lunches and
breakfast is the highest it's ever been
right now about 75 percent of students
are receiving them because of a waiver
from the usda all students are at ccsd
can get a free breakfast or lunch right
now without filling out any paperwork so
what's on the menu
a new
elementary entree salad and it's called
our rainbow crunch salad it has tomatoes
carrots lettuce
cheese and then their choice of dressing
this is a teriyaki chicken salad this is
our vegan burger
french toast jenny o
biscuit
with turkey sausage that's available
all right well the ccsd dietitian says
they're always making sure that work
that basically all the fruits and
vegetables are in there now kitchen
staff are also wearing masks and doing
the hand washing that everyone else is
doing
lunch has come a long way i just used to
get a grilled cheese and chocolate milk
school bus is going to be back on the
roads too on monday the district has
between 1500 and 1700 buses running
students and drivers will both wear
masks when they're on the bus and
drivers will also wear face shield when
kids are getting off and on they will
load on one side and then unload on the
other so kids aren't crossing paths
executive director of transportation
jennifer bobis says there's an app that
parents can use to track where their
kids are we encourage all our parents to
download the onboard bus which allows
parents to track their bus and where
it's at and what time pick up and drop
off is and they get all the routing
information there
now there is a bigger bus driver
shortage than normal so boba says other
people in the school district who have
another job but also a cdl license are
pitching in to help drive
there are plenty of cars to be wary of
too it's been a while since the school
zones were active in some areas so our
traffic anchor nate tannebaum reminds us
of the school zone rules
well we all should know what the deal is
even if we might be a little out of
practice so whether it's 15 miles an
hour or 20 or maybe 25 miles an hour
when the lights are flashing that's your
speed limit lives are at stake and maybe
the money in your wallet also there are
some other frequently broken rules
around school campuses here's one you're
not supposed to flip u-turns around
school zones you're also not supposed to
pass other vehicles in school zones by
the way school zones are active when
there are three things going on either
when children are present when those
flashing lights are on and it also
includes 30 minutes either before or
after school
back to you
good reminder thank you nate well school
police also say there will be plenty of
first-time teen drivers out on the road
so watch for that as well now during the
pandemic school police took the
opportunity to do crisis intervention
training that teaches them to deal with
students who are having mental health
issues now there are concerns there
could be an increase after the pandemic
school police spokesman brian zinke says
their presence will be known on campus
our plan is to have at least two
officers on every single high school
campus and then everyone else will be
supported by our patrol officers they'll
be out patrolling the elementaries and
the middle schools
while a lot of other departments in ccsd
are dealing with larger than normal
staff shortages zinc says ccsd police
are hiring but are only dealing with a
normal amount of officers leaving
we'll changing the grades up next in our
back to school special there will be a
new grading policy this year we break
the differences for you plus what won't
be included in student scores now and
which precautions will be taken on the
field the sports policies to prevent
cobit we are live local now
[Music]
mask and social distancing aren't the
only last minute changes when class
starts back up in just four days kate
houston breaks down the new grading
policy and why some teachers say it's
lowering standards this grade change
takes behaviors completely out of the
question
and it arguably at the detriment of the
student tam lester a teacher at del sol
academy is preparing to use the new
grading guidelines there's a lot of
mixed thoughts the new district-wide
scale sets the lowest grade at 50
percent behaviors such as attendance
participation and late or missing
assignments will not influence a grade
during a back to school kickoff
superintendent dr jesus jarrah says this
will create equity across the district
by having grades reflect knowledge
instead of non-academic factors
las vegas all children will have the
ability
to demonstrate
however lester says this new policy
takes tools that incentivize students
away from teachers and does not instill
accountability what they will need is
those learner-ready behaviors things
like focus things like participation
things like time management
and some of these policies are taking
those away the new guidelines were
approved in early july ccsd is currently
training teachers on how to use the new
grading scale ahead of the school year
and it's not going to happen overnight
and i think it's going to be something
that students parents and staff will
acclimate to lester worries it may be
too big of a shift too soon and i know
the district wants to focus on intrinsic
motivation and that's beautiful but i
think we also need training with that
you know for the past history of
education is focused on classroom
management not classroom motivation kate
houston 8 news now
school board president linda cavazo says
eight schools have already been using
this grading model and have had success
with it in the coming years students
will also be able to revise their work
tracking students mental health
we don't know how how deep the scars are
up next the superintendent talks about
keeping a close eye on students mental
health and what will happen if a covet
case pops up at a school
plus taking the field safely what
differences you will be seeing on the
sports team this year we are live local
now
[Music]
superintendent dr jarrah talked about
how they're dealing with learning loss
an increase in students who've harmed
themselves and what they're going to do
if there's a coveted case in a school
there are a lot of questions to get
answers to so let's start with dr jarrah
explaining what happens if someone
refuses to wear a mask
i have faith in our in our building
principles that are going to monitor
just like they monitor everything in our
schools
you know i feel confident in that august
9th our kids will be following all that
direction and the directives our number
one priority is to make sure that we
have children in classrooms with our
teachers and our educators with our
building leaders and i trust them that
they're going to follow the protocols
and we're going to have school look
everybody is so excited around what
we're doing bringing our kids back up
and that should be the focus of our work
be left here our leaders are ready and
so are we and so are families
all right so the next question deals
with what is the policy if there's a
confirmed kova's case at a school we're
currently working um you know the the
with the southern nevada health district
i mean these are things that are in our
implementation guide our principles we
follow contact tracing our nurses are
phenomenal our administrators are doing
a great job and really making sure the
quarantine process that's why masks are
so important you know i urge this
community to follow the direction of the
governor and our health officials you
know get vaccinated
wear your mask follow instructions so we
are in school in our classroom with our
kids
all right so one concern dr jarr
repeatedly raised last year was the
number of students lost to suicides
which is 24. so what is ccsd doing to
curb those numbers
once we started seeing an uptake up in
the self-harm we instituted like i
mentioned today you know uh beacon alert
go guardian we put it together in the
video multi-leadership district team
every school has a team of
of wraparound support systems for our
kids we the board um you know also
adopted uh panorama the universal
screener for us to be able to see and
the data will show you know we've had
suicide protocols about 600 plus to
protect our kids that work is going to
continue um because
you know great point and great question
we don't know how how deep
the scars are that is also one of the
priorities that we have
the well-being of our kids and our staff
is of our priority
the beacon alert program that dr jarrah
was talking about there is actually a
computer program that tracks students
online activity when they're actually
logged into their school account so it
includes info from their webcam their
microphone their keyboard screen their
browsing history it then sends an alert
to teachers if they need to keep a
closer eye on a specific student and
then get them some help
more students will be trying to catch up
on the curriculum this year than in
years past so data from ccsd shows
second semester grades from the last
school year and nearly 51 percent of
middle schoolers received at least one f
that's more than double what it was the
previous year it was 40 percent for high
schoolers and 31 percent for elementary
students so how are they dealing with
what the school district calls learning
loss
looking at the academic loss is one of
the biggest components that's what when
we partner with nwea map growth
assessment immediately when our kids
come in they're going to participate in
that interim assessment to see they took
it in the in the spring before they left
and now when they come back to see if
there's gaps and then i you know have
the full confidence in our teachers that
they'll be able to address some of those
gaps this is not going to be something
that's going to be solved in one year
you know this is going to be something
that's going to be multiple years you
know so the summer acceleration may
continue
you know and we're going to look at all
these different options for the next
three years
all right so if you have more questions
for the superintendent be sure to let us
know and we will get them answered for
you kristin well denny's spending on
back to school shopping is expected to
be up this year listen to this the
retail association of nevada says the
average household will spend just under
850 dollars the largest spending
category of course is electronics
followed by clothing shoes and then
school supplies well it's game on for
high school football in southern nevada
the silver state is one of the few that
completely canceled their 2020 season as
john treach reports this fall friday
nights will be filled with action and
safety
as the sun sets every august night
anticipation rises for the return of
high school football
this is what keeps them coming to school
this is what keeps them happy and i saw
it firsthand last year where kids were
struggling mentally and were down and
depressed and then it translated to poor
grades or giving up on even going to
school
and
you know i think it's it's important
that we
we have this season gratitude is
sweeping over southern nevada to be back
on 100 yards of field even in 100
degrees of heat
rub some dirt on it mentality has been
retired we used to tell them no matter
what i don't care if you're sick dying
you show up to practice it's like
practice for when you're older and you
have to go to work and it's just a
different world we live in now and and
now we tell kids hey you gotta look out
for everyone you can't be selfish for
the young athletes their life is
consumed with practice
and protocol they're doing the best they
can to make sure that we're safe every
day we do check-ins every day a covey
test daily
we have options to get vaccinated so
they're definitely taking these time
series and making the best out of it in
2020 most states proved outdoor sports
can be done the nice thing is you know
hopefully
kids who are vaccinated will get to get
to come back and they won't have to get
quarantined if something does happen
but
you know as a coach that's probably my
biggest fear right now i don't want to
get shut down for 10 days
and miss potentially two games the
liberty patriots have waited 20 months
to defend their first state title it's
my last ride with my brothers and ended
off with a bang las vegas can't wait to
soak it all in john treach 8 sports now
well practices began this week
competition begins in two weeks as more
students than ever are preparing for
their first high school sports
experience in southern nevada such an
exciting time denise yeah so many kids
were robbed of all that last year well
while students in the clark county
school district head to class on monday
some kids in charter schools started
today more than 300 students registered
for in-person learning and explore
academy at rancho and lone mountain the
school opened during the pandemic so
this was actually the first time
everyone was on campus teachers say the
energy was through the roof and students
were excited to learn hope we can get
back to healing
and get back to the way we used to teach
and the students are going to be able to
learn a lot more now i believe being in
the classroom
although the school just opened it'll be
moving to its main location which is
near simmons and cheyenne we're told
that should happen in the next coming
months however material shortages and
permit delays during the pandemic forced
the construction to slow down so they're
running just a little bit behind
schedule and our back to school special
will continue right after this break
all right christian so we asked the
school district what will happen if a
positive case is found well they're
going to be using a seating chart inside
the classroom to do contact tracing for
other students that were within six feet
for more than 15 minutes and then those
students will have to quarantine as well
still working out how we bring kids back
to school in the age of covid we do have
answers to a lot of your questions from
food to bus routes school supplies all
there conveniently for you on our
website at 8newsnow.com all you have to
do is look for our back to school story
and that's going to do it here for our
back to school special we're always on
at 8newsnow.com along with our app
facebook and twitter that's right we'll
be sure to watch eight news now at 11
o'clock from all of us here have a great
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you